[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
war war never changes the Romans waged
war together slaves and wealth Spain
built an empire from its lust for gold
and territory
Hitler shaped a battered Germany into an
economic superpower but war never
changes in the 21st century war was
still waged over the resources that
could be acquired only this time the
spoils of war were also its weapons
petroleum and uranium for these
resources China would invade Alaska the
u.s. would in Ex Canada and the European
Commonwealth were dissolved into
quarreling bickering nation-states bent
on controlling the last remaining
resources on earth in 2077 the storm of
World War had come again in two brief
hours most of the planet was reduced to
cinders and from the ashes of nuclear
devastation a new civilization would
struggle to arise a few were able to
reach the relative safety of the large
underground vaults your family was part
of that group and entered vault 13
in prison safely behind the large vault
door under a mountain of stone a
generation has lived without knowledge
of the outside world life in the vault
is about to change
[Music]
welcome back everyone it's Charlie big
surprise they announced a new Fallout TV
series based on the video game series so
I'll explain what's going on with it
some of the Easter eggs and what's going
on with the story if you haven't played
the game if you're new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos
of course I'll do episode videos for the
series when it gets here this will be
coming to Amazon as well remember Amazon
does the boys they're doing the Lord of
the Rings TV series I'll explain what's
going on with that stuff at the end of
the video - the intro super nostalgic
narrated by Ron Perlman who narrated a
lot of the intros for the Fallout games
up at least until fallout 4 I think
that's when they switched different
actors doing the voice over the series
is being made by the people who made
Westworld at HBO they have a new deal at
Amazon I feel like that show at least
started out pretty good there were a lot
of complaints about the more recent
season but they do a pretty good job
when they're given the right IP so I
feel like the big thing now is adapting
IP like they just announced The Last of
Us
TV show in development at HBO so pretty
much everybody is making a series based
on video games the plot of the series
will be relatively close to the plot of
the video games there are only some
small changes that they have to make but
I will do a quick history for what's
going on within the worlds of fallout
because it's sort of an alternate
history type of story they are working
in partnership with the people who
created the video game so it's not like
they're just completely doing this all
by themselves they do have the people
who cannot eclis created all the source
material helping them with the story and
the funny thing about this is if you've
been a fan of the Fallout series for a
long time they've actually been trying
to make a fallout TV show for about ten
years if you can believe it one of the
reasons why it's Amazon that's making it
though is because it cost so much money
they just have deep deep pockets to
spend on this but as you see during that
intro there the story begins in vault 13
your protagonist character is called the
vault dweller and he's just tasked with
fixing the water supply before it breaks
within the next hundred fifty days or
everyone in his bunker is going to die
the story actually begins in the year 21
61 but the reason why all that
technology looks like it's trapped in
the 1950s is because there were some key
differences in the way history
progressed the first big change is in
1947 the transistor is never invented so
that's why all the tech looks like it's
super huge and trapped in the 1950s then
in 2037 the robot Butler's that you see
during the
Traylor are created they run on nuclear
power this becomes a big theme things
running on nuclear power in 2044
nuka-cola is created you see it all over
the game like they called the world of
the Fallout game series the Nuka break
universe then in 2050 to the world's oil
reserves start to get so low it creates
a global panic and rush for resources
that leads to the collapse of some major
nations open war and then a strange bio
agent called limit one one five is
discovered by Chinese spies at the
Hoover Dam the vials are smashed in a
public square in Denver which leads to a
widespread release of a mutated new
plague doesn't this sound familiar if
you're living in 2020 it creates this
National quarantine and the u.s. goes on
lockdown so it's almost exactly what's
happening to us in real life right now
then a couple years later in 2050 for
the government Commission's a
large-scale project called project
safehouse which is how the bunkers are
created like you start on bunker 13
during the first game they task a
company called vault-tec to build 120 to
public fallout shelters some vaults are
customized with more creature comforts
than others some are more utilitarian
then some vaults are used by the US
government in a shadow organization
called the enclave for complex social
experiments in ways to create superior
people to repopulate the earth with so
the Enclave is kind of one of the
antagonists of the Fallout series during
the games by the Year 2065 the creator
of the pip-boy devices that you see all
over the game learns that all hell is
going to break loose within the next 50
years so he outfits his hometown of Las
Vegas with all the best defensive tech
a robot army the best that money can buy
in order to ensure his survival he puts
his body into cryostasis in Jax's brain
into a vast computer network housed at
the lucky 38 hotel where he's able to
control all the city's defenses and his
army of robots you wind up seeing him
during present day in one of the game's
sequels but then by 2077 the US
government's shadow Enclave Commission's
a bio agent to immunize American
soldiers against any possible contagion
and cure the new plague that initially
started all this so this is where the
super soldiers start to come from the
virus is then renamed the forced evil
virus but the soldiers at the base were
there conducting this research mutiny
and declared that that area has seeded
from the Union giving birth to the
technocratic Brotherhood of Steel then
within the year full-scale nuclear war
breaks out no one is sure who fired the
first shot or where it was headed but
when that first warhead was detected
mid-flight it triggered immediate
responses from the USSR China in the
United States everyone launched all
their warheads at the same time
full-blown mutually assured destruction
the blast from the warheads were so
volatile that it literally reshapes the
Earth's surface on a massive scale
because there was no warning the vault
system hadn't been finished and most of
the vaults hadn't even finished
admitting everyone possible so very few
people relatively wind up surviving the
initial blast but the ones that did
survive on the surface wound up being
mutated horrific aliy they become the
super mutants that you encounter through
the game since most of the vaults were
unprepared to begin with many of the 122
planned ones wind up collapsing within a
decade in most of human civilization
starts to disappear from existence then
you jump forward in the timeline almost
a hundred years to 2161 and that's where
the story of the first game begins with
you the vault dweller starting on your
mission to try and preserve the water
system of bunker 13 if they go based on
the game initially the main antagonists
the main villain of the series would be
the master who's also kind of a version
of a mutated human who's integrated
himself with a bunker systems computer
he controls all the super mutants and
wants to replace humanity with the super
mutants so there's a basic explainer for
where the series begins and what the
setting is like so it's basically a
post-apocalyptic environment it's kind
of like a Walking Dead type of situation
there are some zombies like you can
think of the super mutants as zombies
but they're way more hardcore than
actual zombies but you do have roving
bands you have people that try to
repopulate the surface so there are all
kinds of different settlements and
people and antagonists that you
encounter through the series my
assumption because it's Amazon that's
doing the series is it'll be 10 episodes
per season and they'll try to do at
least 5 to 6 seasons I just did a
trailer video for the boys season 2
that's premiering in September 4th
that's also an Amazon
series so Amazon is just spending really
big to get really big IP they're also in
the middle of filming their live-action
Lord of the Rings TV series that won't
premiere till 2022 I think I will be
doing episode videos for all this stuff
though I'm really hyped up about the
Lord of the Rings series but it's gonna
be a while before we learn more about
that that's gonna be set during the
Second Age covering the period of
history where Sauron tricked the elves
the dwarves and the humans into forging
the rings of power but everyone let me
know in the comments what do you think
about this new Fallout series it's gonna
be a while before we hear more about
this it'll probably be in development
for most of next year so I'm assuming
episodes won't release until 2022 but
this is just the beginning Amazon
Netflix HBO are developing all kinds of
crazy big series you have all the stuff
that's coming to Disney plus with the
Marvel series you have all the new HBO
Max big-budget series so even though it
sucks right now because of the virus
there is a lot of really really big
content that's coming the next couple of
years while you wait for everything
click here for that brand new boys
season 2 trailer video and click here to
watch Hugh Jackman break down the Marvel
Wolverine movies thank you so much for
watching everyone stays safe I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]